(commanding music)
- The police in Florida are
literally using pictures
of young black men as targets.
Now, how can we see that and
be surprised when it happens
in real life?
I'm not surprised when
Kobe hits a jumper.
That dude practices.
- You don't go to a rally
to beat cancer and say,
"Well, you know, all
diseases matter."
You know what I'm saying?
(laughter)
In the same instance.
You know what I'm saying?
- Well, it wouldn't
be a bad message.
- Yeah, it wouldn't.
I mean technically,
yeah, you're right,
but we're not here for that.
- All diseases do kinda matter.
- They do kinda matter.
- Your wife is black, right?
- Yes.
- You were saying.
Now, if you had to choose
the race of your child-
(laughter)
- Hold on, hold on.
No, no, no. No wait. Let me ...
I don't buy this biracial ...
Your child is either
black or white, okay?
- After listening to those
stats, white all the way.
(laughter)
Thank you. Thank you.
- Hey, America.
Larry Wilmore here.
If you like the Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook, too.
Just don't poke me.
I do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.